the nutrition in cobble classics is  crucial i would say it's really hard to  get  the carbs and the energy in  so we have a lot of  variations from gels to  chewies to energy mixed drinks and with  a lot of carbs in and especially with  we call them the 80 drinks you know that  you have one bottle or 80 grams of  carbohydrates  because the classics are so nervous so  uh hectic it's good to know that you  have like a lot of fuel in in one bottle  basically also with the new better fuel  gels we have 40 grams of carbs in one  gel and  so yeah that makes a massive difference  when you chase a breakaway and you don't  have  a lot of time to to eat  if you take one gel you're sorted for  like quite some time